[Music]
hello welcome to et live I'm selfish
Laci joining me today in the studio is
Bea Miller welcome I thank you so
excited to see you oh of course how are
you good how are you I'm great
so awesome excellent way to start off
the day or I guess it's the end of the
day now happy afternoon right yeah so
first of all I want to throw it back for
a second because I'm sure you do not
remember this but you and I go way back
to X Factor days I used to go to the
movie oh god oh so cute oh they're so
cute are you kidding haha so I used to
interview you at those tapings back in
the day look we've got old school be up
there on the monitor no she's not
stopping it okay so obviously a lot has
changed yes then but tell me what you
remember most about that time oh god how
badly I wanted to get out of it I uh I
guess I just remember feeling very
trapped by the creative aspect I didn't
really feel like I was actually I mean
obviously I'm grateful for everything
that has happened that has led me to
here but it's just like I remember just
feeling very claustrophobic and just
very like I have something to say that's
like my own thing that I want to say and
I want to sing new songs and I want to
wear this and then like you're very much
put in a box and you're very much like a
prop for their show which kind of is not
the best when you like actually are like
you want to say something else you're
like I came here for a reason to talk to
people and I can't even so that was
definitely frustrating and I remember
feeling like that frustration more than
anything but it was also definitely a
cool experience and I wouldn't be here
if it wasn't for that so I'm grateful
but it also is just like I'm just yeah I
thought I'm not there any more
insights always 20/20 would you do it
again though if you could redo it ha ha
I don't know yeah yes and
because I I'm here now because of that
but I also kind of sometimes wonder if I
could have done it without that like if
I really could have done it by myself so
I don't know it just kind of depends
I've heard a quote and I don't remember
if this was Simon Cowell or somebody but
they said anyone who's going to be
successful in the music industry is
going to be successful in music industry
regardless of the path they take to get
there they'll figure it out so whether
that's a silly would say no I also don't
know you know I never I never I like to
just think like oh I have regrets and
trying to go back I'm not trying to go
back in time and change anything sure I
don't really know what is your advice to
people that are going through that today
going through just like trying to figure
out their place in the world I'm trying
to like make a break into what they want
a singing competition just keep in mind
that it's gonna probably make you feel
pretty bad about yourself sometimes and
you're gonna think that people aren't
there to listen to what you have to say
but that's not the case you just have to
get past the point in your life where
where you're not you're not like there
yet you gotta like but you have to you
have to take the steps to try to get
where you want to go and sometimes the
steps aren't the best and the most fun
but you got to sometimes pay your dues
before before people pay dues to you I
know you've said that you felt like you
really had to pay a lot of dues with the
first album - it wasn't necessarily your
words you're writing and now would you
say you're where you want to be on this
album yeah I mean when I when I was
working on the first album I I was only
like 14 15 that was new the music
industry I didn't really know anything
about anything at that point I still
sometimes feel like I don't know
anything about anything in this industry
but I I I remember you know kind of
complaining and being like oh like I
want to write my own song why do I have
to sing me songs blah blah blah
but I can remember having a conversation
with some of some of the bigger people
with my label or just kind of being like
yo be like you're new to this like we
know what's good we've been doing this
for me
years and we are gonna have you sing
these songs and we think are gonna work
for you but then you'll never have to do
it again like just do it now get it out
of the way we'll kind of introduce you
to the world the way that we think is
best and then from there you can write
your own music and they kept their word
on that so I put out that album and
obviously I would never sing any songs
that didn't relate to me that I didn't
feel like you know meant something to me
I only put songs on my record that I
heard the first time be like oh yeah
like I get that like this song I feel
like it's something that I would have
written myself but it definitely feels a
lot better to to be able to write your
own music and be able to put out your
own perspective on on the situation sure
let's talk about the single s lut yeah
how do you do you say it house very slow
I think that the whole issue of one of
the biggest issues is just the fact that
there is such a negative signal
stigmatism around that word I feel like
the original meaning of that word was
lost a very long time ago and now people
just use it to say to say something bad
about anybody that's doing something
that they don't like or as dressing in a
way that they don't like or whatever
women pacifically but it's just I know I
I like to say [ __ ] but it is I guess
politically incorrect but that's the
whole point is that it shouldn't be
politically incorrect and we shouldn't
see it as this word that's they're just
just existing to make us feel bad about
ourselves and we should try to we should
try to take ownership of it so so let's
explain this a little bit for some
people who haven't heard the song yet
it's it's styled s period l period you
period t period [ __ ] but what does it
actually mean tell me a little bit about
the story behind it um the day that I
wrote this song I I was in the studio I
was in New York it was 95 degrees in the
middle of summer it was super hot super
humid it's miserable there sometimes in
the summers obviously wanna wear
something that's light that's Airy that
can breathe a little bit and so I was
wearing this cute little skirt and a
little
bodysuit crop top I mean a bodysuit tank
top situation and the bodysuit had a
scoop back and so I didn't want to wear
but first of all I don't really wear
bras anyway because I have small boobs
and I just don't I don't mean well I
just don't need any support but I also I
especially was gonna wear one that day
because you would have been able to see
the strap in the back like where the
scoop back was you wouldn't be able to
see the strap and I was like oh that's
not fashion-forward so I
wasn't gonna wear one and I was feeling
good about myself I didn't really feel
like I was wearing anything
inappropriate I wasn't it wasn't
see-through even if it was see-through
like screw you still don't say anything
to me about it because sure it's my body
I can do whatever I want with it but it
wasn't either it was not inappropriate
you could see the outline of the fact
that I've nipples but like duh everybody
literally every living person has
nipples so but I just remember saying
this girl commenting something like
something along the lines of you're such
a [ __ ] how could you be encouraging your
fans to dress like this this is so
inappropriate blah blah blah and I
remember two sitting there being like
what first of all as another girl I was
like you should understand first of all
that not every woman needs to wear a bra
second of all you should also understand
that when women tear other women down it
makes it seem okay to men to tear other
women down it makes it seem like it's
okay oh if this girl's calling this girl
is [ __ ] I guess I can too and it's just
like I feel like women are so strong
when they actually come together and
they can agree on something and they can
support each other we're so much
stronger together than we are by
ourselves but it's just really it's just
like it's hard for everyone to come
together because of jealousy and all cuz
of things like that and it's just so
unnecessary we all need to support each
other and I just remember being so upset
and I was ranting probably saying
similar things to my co-writer that day
except John's who's like one of my
favorite people on earth and I guess
while I was talking I'm going off on my
little rant about this chick on
Instagram she typed into urban
dictionary sou T just to see what will
come up and I guess there was an acronym
for sweet little unforgettable thing and
she read it out loud to me and she was
like hey P what about this and I
remember my eyes wide and I was like
what sweet little unforgettable thing
like that's a good thing or who doesn't
want to be that like if that's what that
means that I want to be a [ __ ] and we
were like wait a minute like let's write
a song about that and so I took that
girl's things I'm going to try to ruin
my day and turned it into something to
try to make other people's days a little
bit better
yeah and it's catchy yes I love it it's
such a good story and the response to it
has been so great mhm yeah yeah yeah a
lot of people have been saying really
positive things also for the video I
normally do really concept heavy videos
we're gonna dark I really like the
storyline idea I like telling the story
of the song
I'm kind of making like a mini-movie but
this time I didn't want it to be so
intense I wanted to be free-spirited I
wanted the video to capture what the
song really is supposed to be and so I I
I just wanted to reach out to a bunch of
different women who have completely
different body types completely
different skin tone shapes feelings
whatever from different walks of life
from different experiences and just
bring them together into one room and be
like wear whatever you want whatever
makes you feel comfortable whatever
makes you feel like you're shining and
just dance and just have a good time so
I just wanted to capture a bunch of
women feeling good in their own skin and
so the reaction has been really good I
think people really appreciate that I
just I'm just trying to I'm just trying
to make the world a little bit better
every place yeah yeah yeah one song at a
time I thought yeah and on the album I
feel like self empowerment and and
self-love are really deep themes in
there is that something that you set out
to do when you were making the album or
did it kind of happen organically as you
were working on it
I was I was working on the album I
really I just wanted to capture the
truth because I remember when I was
younger I felt like I was constantly
looking for somebody who would be honest
with me and just be like really like
just truthful about how they were
feeling their experiences and I just I
was really determined to to write
something that I felt like could be what
I was looking for when I was younger and
so I definitely wanted to make sure that
I was expressing myself and being who I
was and not being afraid to tell the
whole truth you know I feel like there's
a lot of times especially in pop music
we hear little bits and pieces of the
truth we hear the good things the things
that people aren't afraid to share but I
I wanted to just talk about everything
and try my best to inspire people and to
let them know that even if I'm on a
stage and you're singing my songs back
to me it doesn't mean that I don't go
home at the end of the day and have a
rough night you know and I feel like
people really easily forget that you
know they look at certain people you
know like all they must have a perfect
life but it doesn't necessarily exist
and we all have our problems and we all
have we all have things going on and I
just feel like the best way to to deal
with those things is to be truthful
about them and to talk about them with
other people so I really just wanted
this album to be me
and really capture Who I am as kind of
an reintroduction of myself to the world
but also to be something that I feel
like could could help people in on any
day not a specific day where they feel
good about themselves or whatever else
sure I mean you do talk about obviously
heartbreak and love and all of those
things as well is that all stemming from
one relationship is it a lot of
different experiences it is a lot of
different experiences a lot of it is
from two specific relationships my last
one in my current one but it is from a
lot of different things in between as
well and I feel like especially at this
age you know 17 18 19 20 you go through
a lot of a lot of changes and a lot of
new experiences in relationships and and
on that level to that extent so I just I
wanted to really talk about everything
and not be afraid of like oh what if
people think this about me or this about
me if I write this song or whatever look
I just want to be like here it is
everybody I guess I was gonna ask you if
you are in a relationship right now see
you all right yeah can you tell me about
that oh yeah my boyfriend Deb he's the
best yes we died definitely in the past
would have never thought that I would be
able to be with someone who's so awesome
because I have gone through some
experiences that were a little rougher
and then with people who are not as nice
to me and sometimes that makes you feel
like you don't deserve the right kind of
love and so I feel really grateful to
have found that in and um so far no mean
songs have been written about me we've
actually known each other for a long
time and when we first met we were both
in relationships I'm a really loyal
person like I don't look at other people
like any type of way if I'm with
somebody so at the time we were just
kind of friends those like three years
ago we just met through a mutual friend
and we always had a good chemistry but I
never really paid attention to it until
we were both single and then I was kind
of like like what's going on here and
then things kind of kept building for a
while over the course of a year and then
now we're here guessin that's that's
just a very wide the very wide
perspective on the story yeah you're
happy oh good I'm glad that's what's
important mm-hmm absolutely yeah
we're seeing some fan questions come in
thank you so much guys keep them coming
I want to ask you one from Josie
year she wants to know what was it like
working with Demi Lovato um Debbie's
awesome she's a really nice person she's
really talented obviously super
inspirational to all of us I'm sure but
uh she's really cool and I just I don't
know I feel I feel like just being
around her and and and seeing somebody
who started so young and is still doing
it still owning owning what they're
doing and loving what they're doing and
loving themselves and also it's really
cool to me that like she's had such a
crazy journey and she's had such crazy
experiences in her life and she still is
so confident and just so so so I don't
know like she just eludes like her she
gives off this positive radiating like
light and I just think that that's
really amazing after all that she's gone
through and it was just really inspiring
to be around that yeah she's pretty rad
yeah she's really cool of her Camila
wants to know well she does want to know
she's just giving you a compliment
you're loving the whole look thank you
know what I want to know is tell me a
little bit about your fashion
inspirations I am inspired by so many
things somedays I love the Billie I
leash look with the over like oversized
baggy situations and like more of a
boyish look with the sneakers and
whatever and then other days I want to
be super cutesy and we're little skirts
or dresses and whatever so it just kind
of depends but I'm really just I'm
inspired the most by people who are
wearing something cool and you can tell
it they feel good in it and then I look
at that and I'm like oh like I want that
and if it was on somebody else that
didn't seem so comfortable and it
probably wouldn't have the same effect
on me so I guess I just I guess I just
look for things that other people feel
good and I'm like oh that would probably
make me feel good and just things I
don't know I different things catch my
attention every day okay speaking of
inspirations Andrea wants to know who
are your musical inspirations that's so
hard I feel like my musical inspirations
change everyday because new music comes
out every day um so one week I'll be
super inspired by Frank Ocean and the
next week I'll be super inspired by
scissor but then the following week I'll
be super inspired by the Steve Miller
Band or you know something that's that's
not as like modern and like in-your-face
and like it just come in depends some
days I'm more inspired by rock sometimes
by pop and sometimes even by folk or
country or whatever else it may be so it
just kind of pens right now I've been
listening
- a lot of Billy I leash I think she's
super cool I've been listened to a lot
of Jesse rants just a lot of like young
women doing cool stuff I loved a new
song with normanni and Khalid I think
that's a really cool song just I've been
really into be young people making music
right now I feel like all of a sudden
all these young people just came out of
nowhere we're like yep we're taking over
sorry everybody so that's pretty cool
yeah that's awesome I want to talk about
your family as well you obviously have a
super tight-knit family do they inspire
you musically creatively anything like
that yeah I mean they they don't
necessarily directly inspire my music
but they inspire me and are a huge part
of the reason that I am Who I am and so
I feel like just in that they do inspire
my music because I I wouldn't be here
writing it if it wasn't for them and
they love my music I always make sure
that I play it for them before the rest
of the world gets to hear it because I
want them to know that they're special
obviously they already know that but I'm
like here's here's this thank you guys
for being here and supporting me and
understanding when I have to travel and
be far away and not be able to be with
you all the time because I'm doing this
and yeah they're definitely really
supportive and they play a bigger role
than I think that they realize oh that's
sweet and I love that you're really
outspoken too about you know politically
and socially I think you're really you
have a powerful message does your family
inspire you in that regard as well yeah
my mom is very liberal my mom is
definitely the reason that I am so
politically involved she's a part of a
lot of really awesome groups and they go
into a lot of protests and they always
are speaking up for what they believe in
just in general my mom is just the kind
of person to say what's on her mind is
not the right time for it I love you
Kimmy I feel like a lot of the reason
that I speak some like so freely is
because of my mom I learned it from her
but I appreciate it you know I've always
felt grateful that my mom is such a
badass and taught me to be one too
because now I can kind of show other
people that it's okay to be a young
woman who speaks her mind and like yeah
people will probably hate you for it
some of the time but
you don't need them anyway who cares
yeah strong Queens thank you
now before I let you go if you guys have
any last-minute questions send them in
now guys what is next for you be are you
touring yeah we're definitely gonna
we're definitely gonna try to get a tour
together for the summer I don't
necessarily know all the details I feel
like I'm used to the last person to find
out about these things but I yeah I'm
gonna get to on tour obviously you
shouldn't put out music if you're not
gonna go sing it for people yeah I'm
hopefully looking for the summer it'll
be either my first headlining tour our
co-headline that will be really really
cool I'm really excited for that and I
guess just keep looking for me trying to
trying to spread my message to anybody
who needs to perfect a few last-minute
questions you're one from Mavi mommy I'm
really sorry if I'm saying that wrong
how did Kim react when she heard mother
love um Kimmy loves mother my mom my mom
loves all of my music she's always been
super supportive I've even shown her
songs that are not released that are a
little more sexual sometimes and I'm
like hey mom like really sorry but this
is a song that I wrote I'm really proud
of it I'm gonna and like I always love
shoving myself and she's always
supportive no matter if it's an
appropriate just a little bit like on
the wild side there's a curse isn't it
or whatever I feel like she's always
supportive and and so mother loves same
things she heard it and she was like oh
well screw that guy for not we're not
some of the right things for you B I'm
like you're right mom Thanks I always
give them some words of encouragement
she doesn't cringe at all cringe a
little bit I actually don't even think
so like Djoser smiles no matter how
inappropriate or wild the lyrics are
she's just like oh well man is proud and
last one here a question from Andrea
what's your favorite thing between
writing and performing that's a really
hard question because performing is
really cool because you get to actually
see that the music that you work still
so hard on the studio writing actually
like matters to people like it's really
cool to actually see people who are
reacting to that in real life and see
your fans right in front of you like
singing the lyrics that you wrote back
to you that's really meaningful but also
those moments wouldn't happen if you
didn't get in studio and write the songs
in the first place so it's kind of hot
for me to choose I just I love writing
just because it's the most expressive
part of my career to me obviously
actually performing the songs is very
expressive but just walking into a room
and and knowing that you can create
anything and and and be whoever you want
that day and say whatever you want to
say is really awesome which is a good
feeling I like being able to walk into
the studio with nothing and lead with an
entirely new song that wasn't there
before so I think that's really cool and
empowering pens
yeah right and it makes me feel good
yeah thank you guys so much for watching
thank you B for being here B's album is
out now so go check it out you guys
we'll see you again next time bye
[Music]
you
[Music]